you saw this on espn forget about porn
for a second and go to something even
less savory espn
uh espn commentator and former football
player i guess dominique foxworth a man
i've never heard of before
because i said not only do i not watch
espn now because it's gone woke but i
never really watched it all that much to
begin with
so dominique foxworth said on a podcast
that he roots against another player on
the buffalo bills josh allen
and it's not because he doesn't like
allen personally or you know he thinks
allen's bad player or whatever
it's because alan's fans are apparently
somewhat conservative and specifically
they have american flags in their social
media bios and because of that
this guy roots against josh allen
my biases are not based on josh allen
it's based on the people that are
defending josh allen i would be 100
lying if i said that when josh does
something dumb
a little part of me doesn't get happy
and it's not because i want josh to
succeed
it's because the people who are telling
me that josh
is the second coming and josh is better
than everybody
are people with american flags and dogs
and skull and crossbones
and their eyes and then if you go just
take a dip
into their tweet history it's some
really
concerning retweets and likes
some really concerning retweets and
likes like i'm just gonna
throw this out there as a guess do they
like retweet
trump or something oh my gosh they do
they retweet
us at the daily wire do they read do
they retweet conservatives what do they
have in the
in the bio they've got skull and
crossbones that's the jolly roger you
know kind of old pirate symbol it's kind
of like you know you see it on some
ties and things like that uh dogs
oh no dogs man's best friend nice
wholesome pet
uh and then worst of all the american
flag
that's bad that's a warning sign
used to be according to the old
standards that the american flag was
unassailable that was the one thing that
we all could agree on
because we all have to agree on it it's
it's the symbol
of the whole country
right it's not just a symbol it didn't
used to just be a symbol of the
republican party
or of mega or of
or i guess we all liked mega right we
all wanted to make america great again
uh it wasn't just a symbol of
conservative it was the symbol of all of
us and so we all saw ourselves there
and increasingly that is not so
i i suspect if you went to the left and
you
showed them either the rainbow flag the
sort of
gay rights now it's more than that
though it's lgbt the whole
uh alphabet line if you showed them that
flag or the american flag and said which
one do you feel represents you
i bet you even straight left wingers
a great many of them would choose the
rainbow flag
because the rainbow flag has become a
kind of it's it isn't even just
a symbol of lgbt anymore it's a symbol
of leftism in america
and it's an evidence not just the
rainbow flag but other
sorts of symbols like this it's an
evidence
that leftism is refuting something about
america and you don't need to look to
flags for that
you can see it in the 1619 project you
can see that in the
you can see that in the protests in the
nfl
protesting the symbol of the country
itself
that now now just conservatives are left
alone with this symbol of america
you